families of political detainees in
Tunisia are looking for justice other
African court on human and people's
rights
Rashid ganuchi is a leader of the main
opposition and harder party his daughter
yusra says he has been in prison for
more than a month our home was raided by
a huge number 100 police officers who
went into the house and took away my
father
uh charging him with the alleged
fabricated charge of inciting Civil War
based on statements he had made two days
ago in which he warned that excluding
any party in Tunisia whether they are
islamists leftists or any party any
component of Tunisian society would be
laying the ground for civil war another
and harder party member said ferjani has
been in police custody for three months
later his daughter believes the court in
Tanzania is the only option it does set
a precedent it does set a tone and I
think not just with
um here but like with the rest of the
International Community I think it helps
us set that pressure and while I believe
that I said is not a rational actor in
all of this I do believe the people
around him are
Kai's side was elected president in
Tunisia in 2019.
since July 2021 he has tightened his
grip on power dismissing the government
freezing Parliament and giving himself
authority over the Judiciary critics
called it a coup dozens of people
including journalists and judges have
been arrested
political detain his families have
called for an independent investigation
into possible human